je parlais avec au niveau liste de ce
qu'a dit laurent alexandre quand il
parlait de ceux qui parlent de dictature
web alors je pense que c'est toujours un
mot très très fort et c'est vrai que
qu'il faudrait arriver à trouver un
petit synonyme mais je pense qu'il ya
différentes sortes de dictature quand
les gens parlent de dictature
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu ils sentent
leurs droits et leurs libertés de parole
et d'expression en fait diminué diminué
sur les choses par rapport à certains
médias et puis la censure qui est
terrible sur les réseaux sociaux
et ça y va à fond de traces surtout
autour du colis je regarde par rapport à
aujourd'hui en fait sur les réseaux
sociaux il ya une énorme censure qui est
fait
je pense que la liberté d'expression pas
sur le fait de nous on peut exposer une
façon de penser sans avoir des postes
supprimés ou des comptes fermés
malheureusement aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
se passera la raison au tour est de plus
en plus avec le co vide il ya une
accélération des choses autour de ça et
on n'arrive même plus en fait à exprimer
sa part expliqué d'accord il a raison
avec aujourd'hui sur un réseau social ou
mettez un poste avec le mot vaccin
qu'ovide etc
vous avez une espèce d'avertissement en
bas donc ça déjà pourquoi on comprend
pas et pour revenir sur ce que disait
laurent alexandre oui on porte atteinte
à nos libertés
puisqu'on en train de culpabiliser les
gens en leur disant vous estimez vous
heureux de vous pouvez sortir ou poêlée
jusqu'à 21h d'or etc afin d'être
ailleurs 23h02 aujourd'hui d'accord
c'était 21h encore hier excusez-moi
alimentaire voyager aller en boîte de
nuit c'est vivre aussi il n'y a pas que
peut un jour la ceni retraites c'est pas
fini en sont les masques a pris 20 juin
c'est fini c'est pas tu vas leur boîte
bon ça m'a totalement libre je suis
désolé c'est là la vie d'avant par
rapport à ce que vous disiez on a on
nous annonce à la télévision qui avait
une accélération fait du coc vide dans
une région de france est la région la
plus vaccinée de france à 43 % de taux
de vaccination la nouvelle aquitaine
comment vous expliquer qu'une région la
plus vaccinée de france c'est là où ça
redémarre et c'est là qu'on est mon
tennis était très bien ce qui se passe
sans nouvelles et qui peine à un cluster
du variant indien qui est beaucoup plus
contaminant que les autres et qu'ils
diffusent plus vite donc pour un même
taux de vaccination on a plus de cas
quand on a des variantes du virus qui
diffuse plus qu'ils sont plus
contaminant donc ça s'explique
extrêmement bien on a vu ça dans
d'autres pays
effectivement quand il ya un variant
plus méchant ou invariants qui diffuse
plus vite et bien on a effectivement une
augmentation des contaminations mais
franchement je pense qu'il faut un tout
petit peu revenir
raison bigard comme tout le monde le
sait a dit a dit que le pass le pass
sanitaires c'était la nouvelle étoile
jaune donc il a comparé la politique
sanitaire de macron à la politique
contre les juifs cependant pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale je pense qu'il
faut être raisonnable oui on a une
limitation de nos libertés pendant
l'épidémie
elles sont en mer dans témoin de palais
au resto ça m'a emmerdé mais d'aller
jusqu'à dire qu'on est en dictature ou
que c'est l'équivalent de l'étoile jaune
c'est totalement déraisonnable je lui
aurais dit que toi tu l'as dit mais
biggar l'a dit des tas de gens l'ont dit
outre ils ont dit comparer le pass
vaccinale avec l'étoile jaune
franchement c'est le semble c'est
honteux c'est honteux c'est honteux
c'est honteux c'est dégueulasse